[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce premier
set 8 journal de 2019 sur tv 78 très
heureux de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle page d'information locale et
nous sommes le mercredi 2 janvier les
titres de cette édition le début d'année
avec la suite du mouvement des gilet
jaune beaucoup sont restés mobilisés
pendant les fêtes le groupe des
clayes-sous-bois et alentour à lui fait
parvenir une lettre sommet à la première
dame brigitte macron ses citoyens
espèrent que l'épousé du président de la
république entendre à leur désarroi nous
les recevons en plateau environ 20 % des
français ont passé noël seul parmi
lesquels des personnes âgées isolées
pour pallier cette solitude une maison
de retraite de saint rémy les chevreuse
a invité ses résidents à réveillonner
ensemble autour d'un spectacle de
cabaret
reportage et puis à les vacances ne sont
pas terminées pour tout le monde
exemple dans ce journal avec une
animation le laboratoire des savants
fous à montigny le bretonneux où des
jeunes ont pu jouer aux apprentis
chimistes avant de développer ses titres
toute l'équipe de tv 78 s'associent à
moi pour vous souhaiter une très belle
année à 2018 plein on l'espère de
bonheur de réussite et une santé à bloc
pas comme moi aujourd'hui elle c'est le
plus important
bonne année 2010 9 d'ailleurs voilà et
pourra débuter cette première édition de
l'année ce chiffre 3 3 comme une
nouvelle yvelinoise sont nés au 1er
janvier ces entités regroupe plusieurs
villes ou villages en un seul fusion des
services
un seul maire et un seul conseil
municipal pour faire notamment des
économies aux autres aujourd'hui pardon
conseil d'installation pour le chesnay
rocancourt ou philippe brillault a été
élu maire nous vous proposerons un
reportage demain saint germain en laye a
fusionné avec four que dans le nord du
département les villages de jeu faussées
de porc villages sont devenus depuis
hier la commune nouvelle de notre dame
de la mer elle est faite sont désormais
terminées pour certains elles se sont
déroulées sous le signe de la solidarité
ça été le cas notamment pour une
résidence de personnes âgées à saint
rémy les chevreuse elle a invité les
seniors isolés du secteur à participer à
un grand gala de noël le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros et de manon 20
radios
ne pas se sentir seul pour les fêtes
opération réussie avec le gala de noël
organisée à la résidence orpéa de saint
rémy les chevreuse les seniors se sont
rassemblés autour d'un repas et ont
assisté à un spectacle de cabaret en
trois volets et puis voir des plus vers
des pays de toutes les couleurs et
forcément ça fait ça fait mais j paul
c'est un spectacle de music hall on se
serait presque au crazy horse
elles sont pas mal les femmes sont un
tout petit peu ça manque d'hommes enfin
bref c'était très bien pour les
messieurs c'est un très bon dans l on a
été très gâté on est toujours très gâtés
du chant de la danse le temps d'un
après-midi les personnes âgées oncle
contre avec la solitude ça nous a sorti
un peu de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
routine c'est un événement dans une
maison de retraite la résidence orpéa de
saint rémy les chevreuse accueille plus
de 300 résidents moi ce qui me satisfait
c'est de voir l'émotion des résidents la
satisfaction des résidents leur sourire
quand ils sortent ce spectacle et qui me
disent que ils ont passé un super moment
et bien voilà nous sommes ravis et c'est
ce à quoi aujourd'hui on s'attache
énormément
dans notre village le prochain rendez
vous est donné aux résidents un
spectacle aura lieu en ce début d'année
pour célébrer 2019 un magicien sera de
la partie
[Musique]
deux personnes m'ont rejoint en plateau
loïc et damien membres du collectif
gilet jaune mouvement citoyen elle
éclaire et alentour bonsoir messieurs
alors avant de parler de votre lettre
envoyée à brigitte macron comment s'est
déroulée la période des fêtes on vient
de voir un reportage sur noël pour vous
pour les gilets jaunes des clés et
alentour comment ça s'est déroulé ce que
vous avez continuer la mobilisation
vous avez fait une pause on rappellera
cette mobilisation qui dure depuis le 17
novembre
on a beau déjà bon soir on a fait on a
décidé de faire une trêve pour fêter les
fêtes de noël après un mois de
mobilisations les membres du collectif
était quand même un peu fatigué le temps
ne permettait pas de rester tous les
jours sur les ronds-points mobilisés
donc on a décidé de faire une trêve et
donc on a décidé de reprendre dès début
d'année déterminer sur tout alors le 27
décembre dernier pendant ses congés de
noël vous avez envoyé une lettre au
sommet c'est une lettre ouverte
citoyenne adressé à l épouse du
président de la république brigitte
macron vous relayer le désarroi de
plusieurs de vos membres ils sont
retraités fonctionnaires pompiers ou
bien tout simplement au chômage pourquoi
l'adresser cette lettre à la première
dame et non à emmanuel macron
directement décidé d'envoyer à madame
brigitte macron parce que c'est une mère
de famille on sait que toutes les mères
de famille sont capables d'être
sensibilisés d'avoir 2
ce regard que n'a pas monsieur macron
d'avoir en fait ce regard de maman
toutes ces enfants de la nation 16
enfants de la république qui n'arrive
pas à finir les fins de mois qui
n'arrivent pas à manger nourrir ses
enfants se soigner c'est juste
incroyable mois dans groupe g des
personnes des retraités qui n'arrivent
pas à manger moins de 7 moins de 1000
euros par mois et il arrive quand même à
penser aux autres à donner aux sdf etc
c'est juste c'est juste incroyable et on
espère que cette lettre ira au bout
desquels nous reçoivent pourquoi pas
mais en tout cas qu'elle du moins
canalisaient avec toute sincérité dans
un premier temps alors sans ressort
également dans votre club titre vous
allez sentiment de ne pas être écouté
par emmanuel macron est ce que vous avez
eu aussi ce sentiment lors de ses voeux
lundi dernier level est la population il
n'a pas nommément cité les gilet jaune
et est ce que vous avez le sentiment de
ne pas être écouté ce que c'est encore
ce sentiment que vous avez eue alors
aujourd'hui c'est un constat évident
venir depuis le
début des mobilisations on a affaire à
un gouvernement qui est complètement
retrancher dans ses agences et voit lui
qui fait la sourde oreille à toutes nos
revendications qu'elle soit pacifique
pacifique ou pas et donc effectivement
on s'attendait un petit peu à ce genre
de l'attitude ou bah voilà on peut y
cote un peu le mouvement on ne s'y
intéresse pas on n'y porte pas enfin
beaucoup denrées qu'il ya fait allusion
mais il n'a pas cité nommément les
gémissements fait et c'est là où
effectivement c'est un petit peu dommage
et
et aujourd'hui bah oui c'est encore une
fois encore une fois dû beaucoup de vent
ou de poudre de perlimpinpin comme il le
dit assez souvent
il ya eu quelques pas fait par le
gouvernement fin d'année notamment la
dose de la revalorisation dans les
mentalités des accélérations de choses
que j'aurais été dans tous les cas
établi peut-être un peu plus tard dans
le mandat mais aujourd'hui encore une
fois il n'y a aucune
enfin aucun aucune réelle réponse
politique à la mobilisation il les fait
que nous répondre de façon répressive en
fait c'est la objectivement c'est un
petit peu dommage donc doudou important
de cette lettre là qui bat on essaye un
petit peu de trouver un remorqueur a
dépassé un peu par un autre canal pour
nous faire entendre quoi juste dans les
autres annonces il ya eu notamment
l'annoncé du gel sur la hausse des prix
du carburant là elle a aussi également
le gel de la hausse des prix du gaz et
de l'électricité ça c'est lorsqu'ils
sont pas suffisantes c'est une réponse
qu'il aurait dû apporter bien aborder
voilà de glace c'est un petit peu facile
de se réveiller effectivement au bout de
plus d'âme en immobilisations et voilà
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il aurait dû
je pense anticipé avec beaucoup plus
d'attention que de se réveiller
effectivement colonisation et 10 rebonds
original effectivement de trois taxes et
ce grand débat national qui dont il a
parlé il va envoyer une lettre aux
français ils annoncé dans ses voeux
grand débat là dessus at il dit je pense
je suis là je pense que ça va être pour
en tout cas à titre personnel la lettre
va lui être envoyée
d'accord avec
je pense un petit message doux de la
part des gels et jaune pourquoi parce
que on ne sommes pas entendus
du moins pas écouté entendu parce que
forcément il ya une il ya des personnes
qui perdent de l'argent forcément des
grands riches de ce monde qui perd de
l'argent forcément donc il l'entend mais
il n'écoute pas qu'est-ce que il fait
pour ces personnes qui arrivent pas
finir la fin de mois il va abaisser le
five had enlever le l'augmentation de la
taxe du gaz
d'accord mais qu'est ce que ça va être
l'année prochaine et c'est là il fait du
court terme nous ce que les mots sur ce
que nous voulons c'est du long terme
un signal fort un signal politique fort
et aujourd'hui la porte pas il nous
reste 30 secondes qu'est ce que vous
espérez au travers de cette lettre déjà
j'imagine qu'elle soit lue par par
brigitte macro qu'elle soit lue et
qu'elle soit qu'elles aient ce regard de
maman j'ai une maman qui
nous me soutient parce que elle elle
sait la misère qu'ont enduré que le des
millions de francs c'est dur quand on
attend les accents en temps de réponse à
quelle qu'elle soit il faut une réponse
merci à daniel merci à loïc d'avoir été
avec nous sur ce plateau juste très rare
diamant rare on aimerait juste inviter
tous les yvelinois notre mobilisation
samedi aux clayes-sous-bois ou au
rond-point de la résistance des 14
heures à une marche citoyenne marche je
rappelle pacifique
on invite vraiment tout le monde tout le
monde tout le monde et on va prouver à
monsieur macron que les gilets jaunes se
sont ni des casseurs ni d une foule
haineuse
on va donner de la galette aux français
qui veulent nous rejoindre qui veut
tiennent des pieds fans et je rappelle
que vous êtes membre du collectif gilet
jaune mouvement citoyen a les clés et
alentour merci d'avancé dans le reste de
l'actualité locale la décision a été
rendue au début de ses vacances de noël
le recours contre la construction d'un
cinéma ugc à plaisir multiplexe ugc à
plaisir a été rejetée par la commission
nationale d'aménagement
cinématographique cette procédure avait
été lancée par cinémovida dont un projet
similaire doit sortir de terre en
octobre dans la zone paris ouest à
maurepas est la société avec l'accueil
de la mairie de maurepas à voit d'un
mauvais oeil l'arrivée d'un deuxième
grand cinéma dans le même bassin de vie
ce projet de multiplexe à plaisir compte
neuf salles et sera érigé au sein du
futur centre commercial open sky dont
l'ouverture est prévue à la fin de
l'année quelques chanceux sont encore en
vacances la reprise de l'école ce n'est
que lundi prochain en attendant un stage
autour de la chimie était organisée à
montigny le bretonneux est des jeunes se
sont glissées dans le laboratoire des
savants fous pour créer une balle
rebondissante le tout sous l'oeil et
sous l'objectif de la caméra de michael
et nidau et notamment ait en bâtonnets
pas de vacances pour la science six
élèves âgés de 9 à 12 ans fait
travailler leurs méninges lors d'un
stage ce mercredi 26 décembre à montigny
le bretonneux
leur objectif créer une balle
rebondissante en utilisant des
techniques de chimistes du coup je vais
tous les pots dans dans le petit mélange
de bord axé de farine la maïzena
du coup ça va se durcir ça va en faire
une petite est une petite boule entre
guinée est en forme une couche sur la
colle forte d'à tribe tat remis sur une
sur une boule d'une valleraugue audi
santé pratiquez la scion sous forme
ludique une expérience proposée par ce
lieu depuis l'été dernier les
expériences scientifiques en fait pour
eux c'est un moyen de manipuler de
découvrir de se poser des questions donc
on leur fait pas du tout en cours
le budget ce qu'ils sentent bien et
qu'il soit amené à se poser même des
questions après avoir aidé expérience
après une heure de manipulation et de
tests dans ce laboratoire premières
conclusions de ces albert einstein en
herbe
j'ai très bien la cherche à chaud c'est
pas remonte au début ça colle en moi je
pensais que cela il fut compliqué les
foules
où on aurait deux ans plus de matière à
la fin du stage tous ces apprentis sont
repartis avec un diplôme et le sentiment
d'avoir fait progresser la science
de quoi susciter de futures vocations et
pendant les vacances des jeunes ont pu
également s'initier à la pâtisserie à
magny les hameaux le service cap'ados
proposé la semaine dernière un atelier
top chef à ses adhérents âgés de 11 à 13
ans l'objectif préparer le meilleur
muffins
après avoir consulté et minutieusement
la recette la dizaine de participants a
pu s'atteler à la préparation des
gâteaux avant de les enfourner à pour 20
minutes
écoutez ces quelques explications des
pâtissiers en herbe et ses réactions au
micro de manon va rétro dans son
saladier qu'est ce que tu as mis du
beurre la farine du sucre en poudre
il est honnête et de la levure
mesdames de beurre c'est difficile c'est
pas difficile mais c'est celle qu'on
voulait proposer avec l'équipe
d'animation c'est un moment un peu
festif entre les fêtes pour partager un
moment avec eux qu'on puisse partager
une sorte de goûter je dois de faire un
simple goûter un peu traditionnelle ont
séduit que top chef c'était une bonne
idée
c'est quelque chose qui marche plutôt
pas mal depuis la fameuse émission de
télé donc voilà il a précisé qu on le
propose
c'est la fin de ce premier journal de
l'année de tv 78 mais rassurez-vous nous
revenons à dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée à tous
[Musique]